this banner reminds residents of the
parapet Rafa Villa and Rio de Janeiro to
stay home but not working and staying
home means going hungry many haven't had
work since business restrictions were
imposed in the city and are unable to
feed themselves or their families now
they rely on food donations some days
they're not able to buy oil for cooking
not even a coffee so what can I do it's
all in God's hands so bad to go hungry
do not have anything to eat and to have
your son ask you for bread or cookie
when you don't have anything to give him
together with a group of ex-prisoners
Jawara da Silva founded the NGO you were
so will which translates to I am me they
are trying to protect poor families in
the favelas during the corona crisis our
approach is to distribute food we also
give them masks and talk to them about
the necessity of wearing them of being
clean and of washing your hands to avoid
being infected by the virus in the
favelas crowded living conditions make
social distancing more difficult here
the kovat 19 death rate is much higher
than in richer neighborhoods for now all
that people here can do is to rely on
outside help and wait for the virus to
pass
pasta Osvaldo Carnival arranges the 16
kilos of food and cleaning products that
are packed in this box it's just one of
a million that will be distributed by
the co mas uno campaign to Argentine
families most affected by the corona
virus lockdown the fear is that as the
days go by if there's no food people
will go out and steal it the campaign
which means lettuce b1 has been set up
in direct response to the pandemic it's
brought together religious and social
groups as well as businesses and
entrepreneurs alone this issue though
the need has forced us to act for a
common good helping people Pastor
Cannavale and his volunteers from the
Cathedral of faith are taking these
boxes to a poor neighborhood in Buenos
Aires for this family it's a lifeline
before there were no jobs now it's even
worse you can't go out to look for work
or anything at the moment I'm unemployed
and waiting to see if I can get
government assistance in another
neighborhood a Jesuit Chapel has begun
distributing lunch three times a week to
200 people elena 7 is one of them she
helps in the kitchen and has also
received a food box herself although she
still gets her salary as a domestic
worker she has to support others in her
family who've lost theirs so it's not
enough we go to eat in the dining rooms
and save on food that's why the food
donations have helped us a lot
Rafael Velasco is the head of the
Argentine Jesuits as much as he
appreciates the corporate donations he'd
prefer it if the richest were forced to
pay a one-off tax we have to give the
state the necessary resources at this
time to be able to deal with the crisis
and I think those that have done better
in some way should make a greater effort
the campaign has already delivered a
hundred thousand boxes and hopes to
raise the figure to a million by the end
of the month